[Music]
Rick Santorum made a huge announcement
you know about this dude Oh Rick
Santorum is we got a lot to talk about
this is big Rick Santorum you heard this
has dropped out of the presidential race
yes Santorum said he didn't want to try
for a come-from-behind win because it
sounded too gay
so looks like it's MIT Romney now I
don't sure does yeah it's being reported
that Herman Cain is about to endorse
Mitt Romney now in other words MIT
Romney is about to get his first black
supporter no one should do it I think in
good shape Oh more money in financial
news the Dow Jones is down for the fifth
day in a row yeah
when asked for comment GOP frontrunner
Mitt Romney said don't worry America all
my money's in Switzerland when I told
the crowd that Dow is everything in the
road they react as if they didn't know
that they're here for my financial news
today is opening day for the Dodgers
have you got that it's their first home
game since Magic Johnson bought the team
yeah there was an awkward moment during
a magics pregame pep talk when he told
the players to get out there and beat
the Celtics
in the late applause in Maryland three
teachers have come forward to claim the
Mega Millions lottery they all said they
will remain at their jobs cool
yeah yeah they want to keep teaching
kids that if you work hard and study it
won't mean crap unless you win the
lottery how is weird is that going to be
for those teachers very strange bring
their gold pin pack head-to-toe Gucci
yeah
hello class hello class didn't do your
homework I don't care
the Seattle City Council has just
decided to classify a woman's right to
breastfeed as a civil right now they're
also also a civil right a man's right to
watch
[Applause]
this is actually what I - oh that's why
there's those restraining orders yeah
exactly the FBI claims that American
universities are being infiltrated by
foreign spies yeah in other words Iran
may now have the technology to build
their own beer bong
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's just looking at it from all angles
last night Melissa Gilbert you hear
about this she suffered a concussion on
Dancing with the Stars yeah it's the
first time anyone connected with that
show has actually seen stars
I love that oh that's not right I get to
have it both ways that way don't you big
news from Pizza Hut
that's pretty much all I have to say
seriously though booties not talking
about the news anymore Pizza Hut is
coming out with a new pizza that comes
with a crust stuffed with hot dogs and
earlier today Taco Bell surrendered it's
that amazing the pizza crust is stuffed
with hot dogs I love to eat garbage but
that does not sound good
dumbest thing you've ever said sorry I
sounds fantastic to me I've never felt
like where this pizza crust needs a hot
dog in it